hey first and foremost I'm always flying
in and out on these things so I don't
get to see a ton of presentations but I
catch a whole bunch kind of little
something here and there
I just want to clap up the last one one
more time because I thought that was
phenomenal I'm trying to always maximize
work so sitting that we're working and
all all the sessions were really good I
was actually able to get a bunch in
today which made it fun but that was
really good I was really like feeling it
and I was like this is really good I was
like listening I was like I believe in
all that [ __ ] I believe in every word
that you just spit but then you got into
the Michael Jordan part and I was like
[ __ ] Jason's cuz I'm a die-hard Knicks
fan and I [ __ ] hate Michael Jordan
period
oh man that sucked and I'm a Jets fan I
got Tom Brady I'm [ __ ] miserable
about sports anyway look I I want to
really take advantage of this format
this is a fairly small group and we're
really tight in here and this is just
like how I love it and so to be very
honest I'll spit a little bit here but
I'd love to do a little bit of QA I'm
not sure how setup they are for it but I
don't even need the mic so I'll repeat
the questions so I think you know the
beauty of Technology is that so many of
my current thoughts are on YouTube and
Facebook right now and especially if any
of you have consumed that even I don't
need to repeat the themes I think
they're basic I think I think at some
level everybody is touched on it you
know I think the thing that I'm most
interested in is the notion of taking it
right to me the most interesting thing
to me is the Internet I think we grossly
underestimate the internet you know the
internet itself is ultimately the thing
that gives us an opportunity to solve
the thing that I think is really in our
hearts and we're passionate about like I
associate so much with so many because
you know my story is I was born in
Belarus I came to the US when I was
three I lived in a studio apartment the
size of the stage I'm on right now with
seven family members and so no matter
what you look like as we all know it's
about what you live where you come from
and to be very frank I'll be very
I just it's interesting I see this all
the time and I'm empathetic that the
system doesn't put everybody in the best
position to succeed but I'm a product
where I think all my struggles have been
my biggest advantage and and really I
didn't grow up in an education system or
a VC system that rewarded me for being a
white male I grew up in a very
interesting path I was a terrible
[ __ ] student I was a DNF student so
like most immigrants I didn't use
education as my way out I was just a kid
that sold [ __ ] right I think like I just
sold flowers and I
I sold lemonade and I'm Jewish and I
sang Christmas carols like [ __ ] it was
my last song like I was I what I did and
really what I would love to leave you
here with like I know the real answer
cuz I've seen it in so many people's
eyes its self-awareness my biggest fear
in this room is that you're trying to be
somebody because you want to be them
versus you figure yourself out and put
yourself in a position to be that person
I think what you had when I watched what
you were just talking about like that
kid was that kid from the get he was
self-aware he figured himself out he was
comfortable in that nerdy environment I
was comfortable in high school working
every minute every second and missing
every party and like I just I have not
heard a voice in my own head but mine
for a very very very long time
and I think what is most interesting to
me right now is if you really pay
attention to what's happening the
Internet has absolutely done this
incredible thing which is there's nobody
who's flawed that can sit in between you
and the end consumer who's stopping you
besides the narrative in your own head
that's a big deal like you know
obviously a lot of people growing up in
the music industry it's just so
different now like just [ __ ] go make
it like producing a song now with
technology and putting it on soundcloud
production and distribution like that's
some [ __ ] we couldn't have you couldn't
even imagine and so I just think I'll be
very honest I I think we're living
through the greatest time to be a human
ever I do we've got problems everywhere
we got genocide in the world we've got
nothing but unlimited problems but I put
thing and I put things into
active like I don't know we got plenty
of problems but the Black Plague was
worse right we got plenty of problems
but World War two was worse like you
know there's just opportunity because of
the Internet not because we've evolved I
don't put this on us like we've still
got plenty of short but the fact that we
have so much opportunity and so to me
it's basic either your dwelling and
looking backwards or your optimistic and
looking forward the problem is you grew
up in an environment you grew up with
parents that put you on the defense or
the offense and that is really the
lottery the lottery really is who's your
mom right the lottery is who's your best
friend the lot there's that's the
lottery I think a lot about and so I
look at I have unlimited white male
friends who have tons of [ __ ] money
in a bank who [ __ ] lost who suck or
in depression because they got the wrong
lottery cuz their mom's broken because
her mom was broken because her dad was
broken and so I am the byproduct against
all the odds that I had of parents that
[ __ ] dominated like my mom is
all-time just all-time she is and so
even when I was getting D's and F's and
all the other immigrant families were
making fun of her because her son wasn't
gonna make it because he had to get A's
and B's cuz that's all we knew in the
80s and 90s
she knew who I was she let me hone my
skills I'd get D's and F's I get
punished but I'm still allowed to go do
my baseball card shows cuz I was
building my skill building my skill and
they taught me work they taught me work
I didn't see my dad until I was 15 and
he made me work in his liquor store even
though we slept in the same house every
night because he'd left before I woke up
and he came after and so we live in this
world now where the fact of the matter
is your Instagram account your YouTube
account your SoundCloud account the
internet like the fact that let's go let
me let me tell you something that
fascinates me because we think a lot
about money and opportunity let me tell
you about an opportunity that I can't
get out of my head which is there's a
website called Craigslist there's a
section called free where people list
[ __ ] that they want to get rid of you go
there and you take it and then you list
it on Facebook market
and you sell it and when I think about
this I can't I've been dreaming about
this for the last 72 hours by the way
like I'm literally doing this selfishly
so do you rock capture this cuz this
videos going out like I you know it's
crazy to me that the only thing that
stops somebody from winning is education
and the work ethic right I understand
that but education comes in so many
different forms I was on The Breakfast
Club the first time and envy thought I
was a motivational speaker like a
[ __ ] rah-rah kind of like the secret
[ __ ] so he kind of called me out I was
like [ __ ] you know it's like he's like
you know you're lying on the radios like
did it and he's like give us something
practical [ __ ] this mindset [ __ ] right
I'm like okay the mind sets the game but
[ __ ] it I'll give it to you and I said
go to the dollar store and go to
Marshalls bite take your phone scan [ __ ]
look it up on eBay and if it costs two
dollars and Marshalls and it's selling
for nine dollars on eBay buy it and sell
it and and that was it it was kind of
like this moment in a 6-minute radio
spot and then it caught a little like
then I read all the comments yeah
[ __ ] or yes then I start getting
emails like yo when I make $500 a week
but I'm making 200 now because I'm going
to the other store and selling it on
eBay and it built in his whole thing and
then I named it the 2017 flip challenge
and we've 10,000 emails of people who've
literally went garage saleing to the
thrift store and the dollar store and
have made twenty thirty forty thousand I
started thinking about the long tail the
long tail of all this right like we're
in this especially like in this
incubator like 99% of startups are gonna
fail in this generation because we're
living through the greatest era of fake
entrepreneurship the amount of fake
entrepreneurs that are in this building
right now is extraordinary
it's true it's true and by the way
please
III know a lot of you don't know me I'm
not sitting on a high horse like I'm a
good entrepreneur and you're not it's
just black and white obvious cuz it's a
bubble cuz I got cool right it got cool
and everybody and it's and it doesn't
cost anything and there's so much money
in the system there's so much incubators
willing to give you money all my friends
for the last 10-15 years are building
all these businesses where it's really
not that hard to use money every month
right I think you on your panel you guys
said as entrepreneurs you know you know
losing money and then making money or
building or I couldn't catch the whole
thing Cubs distracted the problem is it
takes a lot of talent to build something
to then eventually make money and we
spend 99% of our time talking about
[ __ ] slack and uber and snapchat and
[ __ ] Instagram
we got like 17 companies to talk about
and there's 17 [ __ ] companies going
out of business every hour every minute
and meanwhile there's more money being
pumped into the system and it's just all
so obvious right now where this is all
going and it's not very pretty because
we're lacking self-awareness what we're
doing is we're just riding the waves of
what the current conversation is there's
so many people that are gonna be
founders of companies who would have
done incredibly well being number 17 at
this startup or number 94 of that
company or number 167 at that company
but they want to be number one of the
uber of Pancakes right and like so and
I'm watching this and I'm fascinated by
it
meanwhile meanwhile there's so much
practicality let me tell you what breaks
my heart I got a need I get I read a lot
of feedback from my audience there's
I've gotten two examples in the last
three weeks of kids that were making
money on retail arbitrage right so I
think I brought up already the
Craigslist the Facebook marketplace I
think no question if you said to me hey
this is a classroom of like 10th of 16
year olds and they have to make money in
the next 24 months or bad bad stuff
happens I only default in to go buy [ __ ]
and sell it and run the internet
arbitrage become a next we'll spend the
first three months I'll teach you
everything about Craigslist and eBay and
Facebook marketplace and let go and and
then we'll talk about China buying [ __ ]
there and
arbitrage I would spend an enormous
amount of time because the practicality
right now in the inefficiency of the
Internet of buying and selling stuff is
extraordinary in the last three weeks
I've had these kids who you know been
following my content and like Gary I
want to get your advice and basically
both narratives about the exact same way
which is hey I listen to you I got good
I start buying stuff then I hit it big a
bunch of people made a lot of money on
the solar eclipse glasses like you could
literally buy those things for like 16
cents in China
I'm Baidu and then sell it for like $4 a
pop on Amazon people made Bank like I no
one came to make three hundred seventeen
thousand dollars like on a three
thousand dollar starting point right so
it's very real to me instead of I'm
gonna build some crazy app that's gonna
[ __ ] change the world right cuz it's
practical as [ __ ] and and both of them
have made real money one kids made like
sixty thousand this year off of like
$100 base right like these are like real
money and both of them took it all and
bought crypto yes yes and I'm but like I
believe in blockchain is a technology
out my ass the the part of the story he
doesn't know is they bought at
17-thousand right and they bought
and they bought at 17-thousand because
they read 400 articles that said it was
gonna be 34,000 and my like crit by lee
bitcoin could be 400 thousand I'm not
sure I don't know here's what I'm
disappointed in short-term thinking when
he goes who I'm not mad at I'm like
listen maybe long-term like like I don't
know if anybody's money situation let me
give you something that will really work
for you if you don't have to take it out
of Wall Street put your money into
Facebook and Amazon and I promise you
unless America melts over the next 7 to
10 years you'll do well there's
something like there's certain things
are just so black-and-white obvious
right and then everybody else is looking
for a lottery ticket I use an analogy in
a podcast I just did with some good guys
and it hit me maybe because I was in
Miami and stayed at the Hard Rock Casino
[ __ ] hotel which was [ __ ]
disgusting but but a lot of people are
treating their business the way you go
to a casino yeah you could have one
night where you took five thousand put
in the casino but why don't you keep
going every night and tell me how it
works out they don't build Vegas on us
winning and everybody's treating their
business that way right now everybody's
jumping from trend to trend they have no
foundation of what they're actually
doing the writing only headlines and
they're gonna get exposed
instead of taking a meaningful step back
and doing a lot of thinking about a how
exciting it is to eat [ __ ] you know the
thing that the thing that works for me
that I really wished on everybody else's
I loved the journey I loved the game I
loved the struggle
do you know why I keep doing new things
cuz I like when people clown on me you
know why I came out with a sneaker my
own sneaker especially growing up in
that era because I knew people are gonna
[ __ ] on me thinking I had too big of an
ego in audacity and I knew people didn't
think it was gonna work
and that's why I did it cuz I wanted
that struggle and then the high of out
selling future and weekends sneakers
combined that high is the greatest and
the low that's my L when you love the
game that you're in you win either way
you either win and you get to talk [ __ ]
or you lose and your boys get to talk
[ __ ] and you laugh along with them the
biggest problem right now is insecurity
every
these actions are to get [ __ ] to close
their insecurity you need a new pair of
[ __ ] Supremes because you want to
tell people who you are through your
Supremes but you're just [ __ ]
disguising your weakness and so I am
absolutely obsessed for people to start
talking about self-awareness and
patience because they will work now it
might take 15 years it may take seven it
may take nine but if you actually take
tried-and-true things like that during a
time where there's this much opportunity
it's not sexy to walk around and say you
buy weird like candles in China and sell
them on Amazon and make seven thousand
dollars a month but it works and I've
literally sat in rooms and have these
one-on-one discussions and kids have
chosen the sexier thing because we're
playing one big [ __ ] game of optics
we're playing one [ __ ] big game of
optics and like theses super interesting
to me I did really well right here's my
story I made a lot of money selling
baseball cards as a kid my dad worked
his [ __ ] face off and saved every
dollar immigrants have figured it out
it's called make money by no dumb [ __ ]
save it for 13 years buy an asset have
the American dream right versus what's
going on by the way new prediction
because I've been doing some homework
college debt is gonna take the whole
country down I had no idea I don't know
you know I I knew college debt was
[ __ ] up I didn't know the following
thing that I've been doing homework on
the last three days this story is real
and is being scaled across America right
now you're two hundred thirty seven
thousand dollars in college debt on some
interest that's [ __ ] bonkers you're
making eighty four thousand dollars a
year and banks are lending you a half a
million to buy an apartment so just get
ready 2009 s coming all over again I
don't know how long Trump can
artificially hold it up
but shits gonna hit and it's gonna hit
hard and here's what's gonna happen
everybody's gonna blame the colleges
because you know Omar who needed a new
BMW even though he had three hundred
thirteen thousand and death it's not
gonna blame himself for the BMW he's
gonna he's gonna blame Babson and so
colleges brands about to get [ __ ]
collapsed just like the bank's got [ __ ]
on including all these opportunities
that we know are good alternatives
by the way 1930 1940 1950 vocational
skills were hot
then the propaganda of college came
through which is cool because it worked
for a minute it just [ __ ] changes and so
we're living through a really really
really really interesting time because
there's so much carnage in the system
ready to come at the same token it's
never been better for all of us because
the scale of anything you want to do on
the Internet is actually real it's never
been more practical to make a hundred
thousand dollars a year talking about
[ __ ] the Smurfs truth like if you
look at the niches if you would actually
play out a podcast a YouTube channel and
an Instagram account and really
understand how to build stories like my
man just did day in and day out
consistent especially if you know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about and have
patience you will be stunned how much
money is gonna be for you on the other
side of that rainbow and the only way
you'll do it while nothing good is
happening is you'll talk about the [ __ ]
you love the most you can talk about the
1987 Pistons for a living that's crazy
by the way they 7 Pistons really [ __ ]
with Jordan which is why I had to drop
it on my man Jason
I know you do man I got none [ __ ] who I
want to buy the Jets I'm like [ __ ] it
nobody else is gonna do it for me I'm
gonna buy the Jets on with my own Super
Bowl anyway then I built my dad's
business for him
I left the 34 I have no equity in the
business I had even saved a lot of money
because we portal money back into the
business I grew my dad's business from a
three to a sixty million dollar business
I paid back my parents for giving to me
and then I did I I did something really
smart I was building a liquor store that
my dad owned into a wine e-commerce
business and I was using modern
technologies and along the way I
realized that social media was the
second coming of what I saw with Google
and blogging and email and so I just
understood the pattern-recognition so I
was an early investor in Facebook and
Twitter and Tumblr and obviously as you
can imagine that changed the course of
my career but what's really fascinating
to me is that the opportunities are way
greater than they've ever been because
its scale now it's just that all we're
doing is playing lotto I'm a bad gambler
like for example I never taught myself
how to play poker like I don't like
gambling that much so when i gamble I go
I go to [ __ ] like when I go to the
casino
I go to actually like own the casino at
the end of the night like I'm playing
the most high-risk [ __ ] like it's only
like roulette one number put like
[ __ ] $500 on it like none of it is
basic it's all like I'm trying to like
create memories right which is why I
lose all my [ __ ] money that's cool
for casinos that's not cool for life and
that's what people are [ __ ] doing
people are talking about building
[ __ ] businesses and apps and things
that and they're not looking at the math
99% these companies are gonna go away
and it's been good for nine years in the
economy there's money in the system
none of the businesses that are
pre-series be are making any money what
do you think happens when they can't
raise their next round you know many
companies are down rounding right now
all of them like we are not having that
conversation so meanwhile the propaganda
of that or crypto or other things got
people Pumped respect interested I'm
sure there'll be people that win
meanwhile there's all this practical
money and and listen because I grew up
pretty ridiculous you know DNF student
in like like rural New Jersey so like
Hunter boys that wanted to shoot you
with their you know shotgun then I went
to mount I to college and Newton Mass
94% minorities like kids that wanted to
shoot you with different kinds of guns
and so like literally my whole group
that I grew up with from you know first
grade three college
I 98 percent of my friends make under a
hundred thousand dollars a year then I
got into the tech world and these towns
and all my next generation friends you
know 60% of them have eight and nine and
ten figures and I look and I look every
day and I live in this [ __ ] bizarro
world and money is not the variable of
happiness I got boys on to [ __ ]
softball teams [ __ ] working factory
job making 47 K a year [ __ ] happy as
[ __ ] I got friends got a buck fifty one
hundred fifty million in the bank
[ __ ] miserable depression three times
a day at the doctor's like I'm just and
so I'm looking at this and I'm like okay
let's take a step back the Internet is
that maturity we're at scale there's
real dollars to be had if you build a
practical business and we're pumping
people into a casino environment of like
winning a lotto ticket and then okay
fair if you're building a lotto ticket
that's how you win fifty million dollar
companies hundred million dollar
companies I respect that
my advice over here on the practical
side is much more a one to three million
dollar a year business but then I just
look at him like man how many people are
out there right now who would love to
make two hundred twelve thousand dollars
a year and love it and I'm just
struggling with like trying to figure
out how to get this noise into the
system because it's so real it's so real
there's so much opportunity and so if I
could say anything before I go into QA I
really would love to make practicality
and patience sexy I really would like
because that actually changes your life
like that's actually good like if you're
sitting here you're really in like some
need of finances I'm being dead serious
with you you go to Craigslist
it's free you drive your car you take
the TV you put it on Facebook you sell
it for $60 you got $60 like you couldn't
it's just there's so much of it and like
the people that listen to me and are
like angry and have dirt under their
nails that are ghetto like me that like
love it like love it don't make in like
three four five six thousand dollars a
month now
[ __ ] adds up [ __ ] adds up and so like
please think about all the cool stuff
that's out there learn by the way I know
that's what's being pushed down your
throat 99.9% of time so I don't even
have to speak to that let me talk to you
about the point or one percent that's
not the Internet is amazing like really
crazy amazing like we can't we take it
so for granted all of us including the
smart ones in that have been part of it
will look back on me we're all grossly
under estimating what's actually
happening but the Internet is the
middleman for everything it will
suffocate everything all of it
bookstores and taxi companies they're
just first everything what I think is
gonna happen to mainstream media it's
all getting suffocated suffocated retail
suffocated personal relationships
suffocated real estate suffocate it's
all getting suffocated which means you
have you have all the same access as
anybody else you just do it's just true
and the people the middle they used to
just be there because of establishment
they're gonna have to adjust and
actually bring value or they're finished
and record companies and book publishers
and real estate agents they don't do a
whole bunch once that are established
that's the truth they create
distribution but that's become
commoditized and so you need to
understand this truth because when I
look around here we're gonna live for 40
50 60 years like what are you doing like
we got so much time I get fearful when
people are in their 40s you know and
they think like it's a young man's game
like you're gonna be living here for
another 70 years technology is getting
good you can be old and you think you've
so much time and everybody's in such a
rush they're in a rush because they want
to prove something to somebody either
their parents or to their contemporaries
and I'd really like to make it
attractive to be like the person that
went like
listen I think being a tortoise is cool
because you get to win the [ __ ] race
you know maybe your mom or dad thinks
you're a loser right now but like it'd
be much better if you won that debate
instead of rushing into some dumb [ __ ]
to make them think you're not a loser
quicker and that's all I see over and
over and over again and I just think
that this conversation needs to be put
in a system because look there's a big
difference between making money and
raising money and we are become way too
romanticized about raising capital which
has a need and I believe in it and I'm a
VC myself but everybody's defaulted into
it and let me promise you something
knowing how to make money is always a
good skill always and I think it's time
that we start having a bigger
conversation of teaching people that but
everybody's too fancy you're too fancy
it's true people are fancy everybody
likes to put founder in their Instagram
profile like it means something I cup a
basketball player in my [ __ ]
Instagram account doesn't mean I playing
the NBA [ __ ] and so that's the
problem right now we've romanticized
something it's very easy to say you
can't say you're a professional singer
because everybody call you out we can
see it you can't say you're a
professional athlete but you just put
that word entrepreneur and co-founder
and you are it but you're not you're
renting that status there's a big
[ __ ] difference between being an
entrepreneur and being a successful
entrepreneur and unfortunately we have
confused the lines and it's putting
people into really bad bad habits during
an easy time if you're under thirty one
in this room
you've never been punched in the mouth
professionally which to me means you're
[ __ ] soft it's not your fault you
might be able to handle that punch but
you didn't live through 2000 and 2001
and 2008 or not definitely not 90s poor
and like you haven't been punched in the
[ __ ] mouth and so like you're not if
you're not if you've been doing
something for two years right now three
years and you're not winning and it's
this easy you better rethink [ __ ] now
yesterday
it means maybe you're number three and
you should go find a one it means maybe
you're dreaming and playing lotto and
you need to get practical because this
has been the easiest [ __ ] time to
make money in the last hundred years and
if you haven't figured it out you just
might suck I'm serious it's true
like it is cold but honestly I'd much
rather give it to you cold giving you at
least a thought to think about it
because it's [ __ ] true cold instead
of [ __ ] pandering to you and then
when you [ __ ] crash and you really
hurt in like all those people that said
rob rah you can do it they're not around
and so please get practical please learn
how to make money if you're a business
person and so that's where I'm at
I'd love to do some QA thanks for having
me
you
[Music]
respect so everybody that creates a
channel can set their own price people
paid them directly yes we split their
revenue between fifty fifty yep and you
can use crypto okay I want to know you
were early a YouTube yep
you want to be earlier reflections
probably not but let's talk it through
so the first thing that's interesting is
what's that what's the revenue share
it's a 50/50 split
so Apple gets 30 cent for every dollar
we split the rest with the content
creator so so the 70 that's left do you
mean correct 35 cent to the Creator 35
cent to us and so what are you doing to
get my 35 cents so we're incentivizing
influencers right now to sign up for the
app and be a part of it won't be
launched at South by Southwest right so
you think that you're gonna get seven or
eight people that have a little bit of
an audience and that they'll be able to
then because they're on it get other
people to jump on yeah so we had a
hundred users in it from LA yeah some
top influencers and some creators that I
can't mention right now but they are
influencing you yeah usually the reason
and I've seen a lot of apps like this
usually the reason this app scares me is
because people underestimate people love
to say yo you need to come on my thing
and I've seen this show over and over
because you're on YouTube or you're on
Facebook or you're on Instagram and
they're not paying you [ __ ] you need to
come on mine and that's how we're gonna
do it which is the right argument right
the problem is those platforms have
[ __ ] eyeballs
everybody's a big shot when instagrams
[ __ ] giving you the algorithm and
Facebook and giving you the awareness
but when you go over sup to a new
platform and now you're asking your
audience for their money and there's
nobody actually there that model has
been a real difficult model to happen
there's a very big reason why there is
still no platform for content that is
working that way in a world where
influencers have been real now for 13
years
don't let this current state of
Instagram like trick you
long before Instagram there's been
influencers on YouTube now for 12 years
there's been influencers for a very long
time in a lot of places when you ask
people to pay for content that [ __ ]
better be real because it's unlimited
[ __ ] content
out there and second of all everybody
thinks that they can move them but every
one of these a listers over the last
five years digitally have done some
version of their own app have been given
equity in some new startup that has the
same exact business model as you and
none of them have popped because when
you try to drive people away for from a
free platform where there's a lot of
other people to a place where you have
to pay for yours people get exposed for
not meaning that much so I think the
biggest thing you need to and then of
course you're doing the other move that
a lot of people do which is like if we
get seven or eight people that have a
look have an audience well maybe that
momentum can carry through the problem
is when people start going to a paid
place they start trying to get their
audience to come and pay them over here
which starts making them lose their
audience in the free place and that
attention was the currency they had in
the first place and so they start losing
on both sides there's a very systematic
reason why this model has not worked
consistently for the last seven years
including companies that have had twenty
to thirty million dollars in funding so
I would just say please do me a favor
and like really really go do the
homework on the ten to fifteen that have
died over the last four or five years so
you don't make those same mistakes
because I don't believe that you may not
figure it out I just know it's a lot
harder than people think
because the theory of Facebook and
YouTube is [ __ ] you is ridiculous
they're the people that put you on in
the first place you're not paying
YouTube and Facebook and Instagram for
those hundreds of millions of potential
views so that you gotta got to think
about that Thanks you got brother hey
man what's that
quick question Eugene so I'm serial
entrepreneur and then I went into
corporate America made a most of six
figure income and that has just walked
away from that to go back in the tech
because I I couldn't breathe basically
back and so I just started a tech
company yep basically what we do is we
do marketing for small businesses we
take their customers and we know
hundreds of customers that come in at
door every single day we turn them into
a marketing resource so we get them to
promote on social media for discounts
and free stuff or you know drive Yelp
reviews and things of that nature
so it's built our our entire platform is
built on top of the facebook Messenger
application and so a lot of the
conversation is all chat by AI or
Loretta understand um so I just wanted
to kind of get you a viewpoint or that
that probably says I like a lot of what
I'm hearing well I like the small
business part I like the practicality of
it like the longtail in that world has
not been exposed Facebook continues to
think about it every day you know it's
where Google makes its money the
longtail is extremely profitable and a
lot of people aren't focusing on it the
only thing I would tell you that made me
kind of think that I would if I was an
investor a partner I'd be like hey
incentivized actions to help a business
usually ultimately break so just keep in
mind the psychology of like what happens
when you're incentivizing an action the
end consumer eventually understands it's
flawed what yelps you know anonymous
breaks for the same reason
eventually the data the content isn't
valuable the fact that everybody just
heard that you have a business that
takes a customer that comes to a local
business they get a better deal to write
a review on Yelp has already made them
not like Yelp as much anymore
Yelp was cruising until people started
having friends or dating somebody who
worked for a PR agency that wrote fake
yelp reviews when you gain the truth you
become vulnerable so I would be very
thoughtful about what you're
incentivizing so it doesn't become the
vulnerability of what you're building
you stay away from that one
vulnerability every other thing is right
AI messenger hasn't even started it will
be a huge space SMB spend on social
media hasn't even started it will be a
huge space
just give thoughts to the last part
let's take it you got it how are you
good how are you good what's your name
good my name is Victoria Queen okay I'm
the global brand manager at eBay awesome
yeah and I just found it very
interesting that at your core buying and
selling yeah this is who you are yes and
you know as part of my job I'm thinking
about the future
I was actually spending some time at the
longshot the long now foundation and
they're building a clock to last for
2000 years and I can't help but but
think you know we've evolved so trade
barter Commerce ecommerce you talk about
Craigslist you talk about being
practical how do you think all that's
going to evolve in two thousand years
from now what are your thoughts of the
future so first of all my first thing
that ran through my head is like
Victoria I love you but I'm not [ __ ]
Nostradamus that's the first thing that
I thought of look I I think in that you
know I think one thing if you study
human behavior when you start getting
into hundreds and thousands you start to
see circles right so I think technology
is getting awfully close to barter do
you know much dumb [ __ ] everybody in
this room right now has in their home
and then somebody else has dumb [ __ ]
that that person wants like I'm
fascinated by barter in such an
interesting way
look we're always gonna trade it's
always that you know back to the woohoo
in the audience like crypto so fun
because it's opened up so many different
thoughts in my mind the fact that I can
Tran the fact that you can sell me your
home and we can do that in the
blockchain and all the people in the
middle that have nothing to do with
anything get cut out and all those
economics go back to us energy bills
like you start looking at some as 30
percent of the money you're paying for
your energy in your home is for people
in the middle that do nothing so we're
getting closer and closer to a world of
us which i think is super fascinating
massively vulnerable for governments
which is why I think it's not gonna
happen so quickly I mean if you really
understand blockchain like China America
and Russia are not in the business for
allowing it to actually succeed because
[ __ ] then we become one team like like
you take away currency bombs
to think the only thing lat like it gets
really kind of like I don't think people
are playing people are so obsessed with
Bitcoin they're not even on a theorem
they're not even on plot chain like this
is real technology you're right I am at
my heart I mean like basically I taught
my brother how to be an entrepreneur by
garage saling and selling on eBay like
to my favorite hobby in the world and
I'm not pandering to you right now you
can go watch all the film for last 10
years
my favorite hobby like I can't [ __ ]
wait to March in April so I can start
going garage saleing on Saturday morning
I get a bigger high of finding some
random little [ __ ] toy for $0.50 at
somebody's house and selling it for $6
on eBay then I do closing an 11 million
dollar deal for vaynermedia and by the
way it's not even close
and that's why I keep doing it back to
like what you had to do because when you
can't breathe what are you gonna
suffocate and so like I think it will
continue to evolve I think it's getting
more and more interesting what I'm
really interested in is between your
platform Craigslist lecto Facebook
marketplace there's ARB right there so
like I'm just like it's unlike you don't
even have to be like if you want to be
efficient and actually make money and
not just do it for fun like I do you
don't need to leave your room and just
buy [ __ ] in between the five platforms
and find the arbitrage it's crazy it's
crazy it's an amazing time for retail
like it's just an amazing time you've
got big-box retailers going out of
business but we can like if you ask me
what is the one thing that everybody in
this room has the best capability to
build a $500,000 a year revenue business
that gives them $200,000 take home
it is absolutely retail on the internet
and it's not even close and if you
really understand how Amazon Shopify
work with those platforms then you can
sort I mean the fact that you can
basically create any t-shirt company use
Facebook Ads to target any long-term fan
right like make t-shirts that like I
grew up in Chicago in the 90s right run
it in front of him he's like I grew up
in Chicago in the 90s [ __ ] it I'll buy
it
have a shot like it if you understood
how to run facebook at
facebook/sewingpartsonline I'm the ads
are so low the margin on t-shirts so
high I can just run that at scale and
make 200 thousand a year no problem yet
people are trying to solve problems like
build these billion-dollar platforms and
they're all gonna lose and they're all
gonna be going like if he doesn't make
it practical soon when the economy
decides to do its thing he's going back
to corporate America he has to make it
profitable like it's just the way it is
so I don't know I'm really starting to
get passionate about like let's get
practical like I know it's fun to create
the next ways I know it's fun to create
the next Instagram it's just the maths
against you meanwhile all this money is
sitting in the system and it just feels
and guess what back to like some of the
themes like nobody's stopping you
there's no boss there's nobody who hires
you there's nobody decides the internet
doesn't give a [ __ ] if you're black
white girl alien the Internet's the
Internet
that's why it's the best we will never
achieve what the Internet is gonna do we
will never get good enough we're too
[ __ ] flawed unconscious bias is not
gonna get fixed anytime soon the
internet doesn't give a [ __ ] so take
advantage instead of like dwelling or
being pumped or whatever the [ __ ] side
on things you are just take [ __ ]
advantage attention is like real estate
right the internet is so young you can
still buy beachfront property we weren't
around when Manhattan was [ __ ] some
do you understand a human being bought
an acre in Manhattan for $2 you do
understand that happened right it seems
ridiculous but it happened let me just
remind you who the biggest spender of
Google AdWords was in the first five or
six years Amazon and that's why they are
who they are and right now you have
Instagram influencers you have Facebook
Ads you have real underpriced attention
to do anything you want your people that
are now used to buying e-commerce like
there's so much opportunity
I just think we're looking in the wrong
places you know okay you know what it
feels like it feels like there's like
dollars like on the ground right and
there's just like a huge sign like a
trillion over here and you're like and
then just fall in the pit and there's
all this [ __ ] money [ __ ] let's keep
it going hi how are you you can get the
next guy oh hi hi how are ya good I'm a
little nervous
don't be but because you might blast me
I want to end up on YouTube I don't like
rush laughs bless you but basically my
my project is called the black bay area
basically we follow black people yes I'm
from Oakland and I'm from Bay all day
and so for me it's really passionate
because I saw a lot of black people
being here a lot of gentrification
happening yep and they wanted to tap
into the black community yes without
being a part of that gentrifying
mechanism that's being here being in
tech you have the monetary means to buy
big million-dollar houses and
marginalizing people who really need the
support and extra help um so for me it
started out as a joke like I do bay area
bay of the day and shout out people I
also shout out a lot of small local
black owned businesses yes now the way
I'm scaling this to be monetizing as
I've been doing like smaller events yes
to get my name out there but we launched
I'm launching a website it's gonna be
the black Bay Area org it would be a
larger ticketing hub so if you want to
go on and tap into any black event
locally you'll be able to buy the
tickets from me instead of like a
Ticketmaster or Eventbrite you'll just
go ahead because I'll be the word on the
street okay so I've made those
relationships with the promoters and
people that want to reach out to tap
into the second aspect is gonna be
ecommerce now I'm not didn't lay it all
out all at one time like I'm just
walking you through the three thing I'm
focused on is the second one is
ecommerce from smaller merchants so if
you're from the Bay you notice one thing
that you really really want then I'll
have it on the site the hottest product
that a smaller local vendor will have I
don't know how I'm gonna monetize it for
myself but I know it's in
important for my community to have the
visibility of someone going to a ticket
hub that reflects of the community they
can buy items from the community the
stuff that's hot that you normally you
don't have to go to flea market you can
live in Boston but still buy like every
end gentles barbecue sauce the third one
is going to be real estate so I'm
looking at black real estate investors
to see I'm not investors I'm sorry
militaries to post listings for homes to
do roommates for black people who want
to roam with black people but also know
it's real there is real a life though
it's real life I'm left so I mean know
people getting two-faced and mayonnaise
and stuff like that is really really
important now I mean there's mayonnaise
in two phases and things like that there
people are having uncomfortable
situations and those cultural
conversations can't take place to where
they can feel comfortable so they are
looking for someone who can understand
their culture and how they grew up and
where they're from
I greet take a step back how long have
you been doing the media content
I'm wrapping up on my seventh month
social are I have had about 6,000
followers on Instagram I have devon
franklin i have i am su i have local
notoriety from people just trying to get
their their word out there about their
business because a lot of instagrams and
a lot of things that are showcasing
black people are showcasing someone in
the front saying hey this is my brand
I'm not doing all that I'm putting the
people first and so that that's my goal
is to push their product push them but
also figure out how I could stay afloat
because right now I do it from the heart
I don't do it to like I don't bet on
this and put my life money I'm working
it like I won't want somebody to work
for me you know there's a lot of themes
here that excite me and a couple things
I think you should think so first of all
my biggest belief period right now is
that everybody in this room and their
businesses are a media company first
comma then you do something everybody
like every single business you've got in
here no matter what you tell me you do
my man over there with the with the
video platform he's a media company
first comma he's a business that's how I
actually think the next 20 years play
out that the that there will not be a
single business eBay tomorrow she needs
to hire their editor-in-chief for real
not branded content not the way most big
corporations do it all the way down to
the smallest business idea here media
company first comma then you do what you
do
that all the upsides there because the
media is so under priced and there's so
much awareness
you've naturally intuitively done that
you you've started with media now you're
starting to see there's something pop in
a little bit you're like wait a minute
I'm gonna make some money on this thing
right not that you started there because
I'm listening to you now that you
started there you're debating whether
you're gonna do that right you're
debating that you're not sure maybe you
want to I'm sure you know you're still
early at seven months you know let me
tell you a couple things number one it's
very easy to start allowing no matter
what too much of the Commerce to cut the
reason it's working is cuz it's pure the
church and state that you have to do
between this content and what business
you want is extremely important it's why
I work I put out so much content in the
business world for free and I have no
interest in any of your money I come out
with a book but I'm asking I'm not
interested there's no top of the funnel
retargeting you I don't hold something
back and be like now you got to pay
[ __ ] you know like like I'm
putting it all out and letting the Karma
of the relationship work out and
businesses struggle with that so much so
that I don't monetize my personality
I've always run other businesses a wine
store in an agency that tries to get the
big companies not the audience that I
speak to I think a couple things number
one if if if I could convince you to not
have be thinking about this right now
for another two years it would be the
first thing I would tell you now you may
hate your job or how you pay for your
living and so you want to get over to
this as quickly as possible but I can
tell you right now if you can wait
longer and not spend any mind time on
that but triple down on what you do well
so for example download anchor right and
start interviewing these local
businesses and start your pod
tomorrow become a media company take
that podcast transcription and use
Mechanical Turk or some outsourced
people or an intern and now you've got a
medium post or a LinkedIn post now you
got written content go ahead Mike like
sorry
oh so I've already started that so
because I'm not a media person I come
for more of a non-profit sighs yep and
so I have someone we have people writing
from the community on our medium blog
people look at it we also I do a lot of
I'm hosting a free photography show for
people in the community like I do a lot
of things so it's just the fact that I
think I want to hone on a ticketing
because every time I hear people when
they come here especially black people
they're like what's poppin tonight
what's going on I just want that single
website for the ticketing portion to be
really important because I think that's
a motivating motivating factor Freddie's
looking looking said the multimedia two
things it's so early you're seven months
in and have you debated bringing in a
partner yeah baggage
yeah but let me let me tell you let me
tell you something about your trust
issues if you asked me to put if you
asked me and I'm listening and we're
vibing right now if you asked me to put
my children's health on the line of can
you run a successful ticketing internet
company I would bet against you and so
I'm like I'm being serious with you like
I think you clearly have some like you
told me about your background which is
where your passion is
you're clearly hitting a chord you're
only seven months in like that's exactly
right that's what happens when you're on
to something and so it's moving faster
than you expected who you're on to
something which now gets you to start
going into a place that you're not as
comfortable with like you're you
spitting out ticketing and retail and I
heard you not all right away but
ticketing and retail and then you know
what was the third thing you were saying
real estate I get it I get it but it was
a hot [ __ ] mess like like your
thought process there was a hot mess
like I'm telling you it's a hot [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] but your first part is so
off the charts right that you need to
[ __ ] start interviewing people you do
trust and figure out to bring somebody
who actually knows how to do that part
the biggest problem is people want to be
everything like like want to do
everything like we aren't like I
couldn't get any entry-level job in my
own company because I couldn't pass the
write written test or the math test for
the two disciplines I couldn't I own the
whole [ __ ] thing and the scrape facts
are I could not work with my own company
in an entry-level job that is the truth
that's not me making a joke that is the
[ __ ] facts there are a lot of people
that know how to build simple tech nope
first of all they wouldn't build tech
they would rent the tech over the
ticketing platforms and the econ
platforms and the real estate platforms
and pay nothing for it they want to get
ripped off by somebody to bill it I get
it but like you need to do what you do
and what you do is you have a pulse so
what the [ __ ] is actually happening and
you know how to story tell it that's
where all the leverage is if you had six
million people on that Instagram account
you could sell a lot of t-shirts a lot
of tickets have a lot of classifieds
you're only seven months in this thing
has just started back to the thing I
talked about you're a young young young
woman you may look at some 19 year old I
saw some 19 year old turtle earlier so
I'm like [ __ ] that's young you know but
but you are that young you are that
young for you to do something that makes
you happy for the rest of your life if
you go into a coma for six years and
just focus on what you do you have a far
better chance of being successful then
trying to decide that you're gonna be
the one navigating the business aspects
especially because I heard you spit the
way you thought about it and you're
you're clearly not very deep into your
business mindset yet which you mate
later on do but like I think you need to
either do one if you I'm trying to give
you really good advice you do one or two
things bring in a business partner to
try the business part so you can focus
on the content or stay focused on the
content for another 15 months and
revisit it later those are the those are
the options in my opinion I could be
wrong but that's what I'm feeling
I get it patience is a strength that
people think it's a weakness cool you're
welcome one more all right I'm gonna see
how that's okay um since you're a media
muscle I'll get I'll get YouTube don't
worry since you're a media mogul who's
who's built such a successful company
and you're looking back at it from
perspective you know where you are now
what first steps would you take in terms
of creating a media entity or a media
company you know saying you had zero
followers or zero funding or really
scrapping it out to create a content
driven business I think the only I think
the best advice for content driven
business is to scratch your own itch own
itch like make the media company the
blog the Instagram account that you wish
existed because you know it you know it
you're one of it like the we are guys do
you know how big forums still are on the
internet like 1994 technology because
little groups little neighborhoods
that's why the young woman who's just
talking was going to the bathroom I hope
right now it's like like that's why it
worked because it was nice it was niche
people I'm telling you man people try to
boil the ocean go narrow like you know
like go narrow like barstools winning
cuz that team made what they wanted they
wanted irreverence they wanted to mix
culture a different way like you've got
that's the only way to break through
except understand it's an incredible
time but all of us can do it so it's a
supply and demand issue right it's an
incredible time it's an incredible time
but everybody can start one so it's easy
and hard which means to me go deepest
[ __ ] like go very narrow to what you
know right and go deep deep deep into
that I think that's the place to go and
then use the modern places where there's
attention you start a media company
today you should be voice and social
first not website and email first
because it's underpriced attention you
can take that
from Instagram or a podcast and then
start a website I bought pure well
women's lifestyle business back a year
ago and I'm gonna launch a men's one and
it's all gonna be launched on the back
of my audience and I built that audience
and social and voice and I'm gonna
penetrate it to a website and other
things as well and so I have it already
and so we all have that too we have what
we have we have our lives our passions
our interests I want people to go narrow
real narrow there's a real longtail
business really there is I mean really
there is so cool I don't wanna do this
guy well thanks so much Gary actually I
have to have to thank you for all the
content because I actually I put an on
on the streets and it works
my problem is I'm a doctor and at offer
yeah for sure I'm glad surgery and
pretty good as well actually and I have
an angel investor a and I have one
startup as a CEO okay and the problem is
about following your advice we put
everything on streets no we documented
everything and we've got a good problem
because we have our audience we build
audience for my patients and we have
audience now for our entrepreneurs guys
that are gonna make the same same path
yes and now the problem is when people
go to my name they can find both and
maybe some patients like say hey I wanna
make the nose job with this guy because
they they don't have full time on Justin
yet yes and the other side you're
looking a bit wrong you know what I mean
well because you're looking at the
downside not the upside it's like I
asking you because this is a little bit
new for me nope yeah it's all this
audience and how people make it well
send emails and direct on Instagram who
I want to be a business on your field
and actually I wanna be make a boot so
it's well super interesting to have you
here because I think one of the things
I'm trying to figure out is the people
that are taking my advice are winning
yeah I can say it's works for sure is
work yeah you can't buy these books yeah
this works what about that what happens
is they get into the crossroads that
happens to you which is you're trying to
do it to build your chiropractor company
your your your yogurt shop you're
surfing knowledge and then what's
happening is you're getting inundated
now with people who want you to teach
them
how to do that for theirs look I think
that's to your point you said it very
quickly it's a good problem I would
definitely tell you not to worry about
it right like I I have so much if you
look at my Instagram content right happy
day thank you
if you will but thank you but let me say
when you look if you look at my latest
post my latest post on Instagram is me
hanging out with gonna the up-and-coming
rapper from Atlanta that is not
necessarily what Chase Bank and an ABI
and sa P my clients want to see from me
but the truth is the truth yeah I run
the best agency and so they're gonna
hire you if you're great at your craft
there's nobody who's not gonna come to
you because you're teaching other people
how to build a business
it will all be net positive don't allow
yourself to look at the negatives of or
perceived negatives or issues you're not
you're gonna for every person you lose
that says he's not spending all his time
on that you're gonna get three others
because you are spending on it for them
give a [ __ ] to themselves it's a it
life's a net-net game do you understand
too many people are dwelling on what
they're losing without understanding
that those same tactics make them win
when I started speaking in 2009 I cursed
thought and I didn't wear suits and you
know there's a lot of youngsters in here
this may seem foreign but that was not
super [ __ ] acceptable just eight years
ago and I would get emails for then I
got a speaking agent and I would get so
many emails literally CIA my agency
would call me once a month to say if you
stop cursing we can get you four more
speaking gigs a month easy and I would
reply consistently for three years
[ __ ] if I stop cursing nobody's
gonna listen to me speak because I'm not
gonna be me right and so and I guess
what I won because the world changed
when you're yourself and your true
that's why Jason I really loved what you
were talking about could you imagine how
much the world has evolved let me leave
you with this as you're thinking about
stuff if you told the parent 12 years
ago that when
have a fifteen-year-old daughter they
would rather that fifteen-year-old
daughter go into a strange man's car
four times a day instead of driving
their own car they would have laughed
you out of the room but if you live in a
rich rich rich neighborhood and your
daughter turns 16 the big new gift is
not a new Benz oh the big new gift is
unlimited
uber it's it's right it's true could you
imagine if I had a video 15 years ago
and say one day in 15 years all of you
are gonna send your 15 year old
daughter's into 43 year old weird Benz
cars 24 hours a day they would have
laughed me out of the room norms change
norms change to be very honest this you
know especially when I talk to my
friends and minorities and like urban
culture is America's culture now like
when Mayor Bell and I am talking about
like it's just the truth
like like it's just the truth like go
show me anything that's popular I'll
show you where it started Atlanta you
know like like it's just it's so basic
it's so basic like literally if you told
me my mission as a Brander over the next
seven years was to get 15-year old white
women to buy something I would start
with rappers in Atlanta because that's
how it ends up there and so you can run
away from things you can like look at
things I just think that no matter where
you are or what you are look at hip-hop
I'm 42 I grew up with hip-hop where guys
faked how hard they work cuz their aunt
lived in Oakland and they visited her
once a year and they said they were from
Oakland but they weren't [ __ ] too
short you know what I mean they were
[ __ ] [ __ ] but in 1992 93 94
people remember you had to make pretend
you were hard because there was only one
move lil yachty would have got his face
beaten in 1992 yeah right but if you
stayed true it would have come to you
because now everything is acceptable and
so everybody's deviating into something
I say put your [ __ ] flag on the
ground of who the [ __ ] you are I have a
funny feeling it's gonna come to you
especially with the way the world is
working now because what all this Harvey
Weinstein and Matt Lauer stuff
it's all very simple it's over the
internet there is no hiding everything
will be exposed do you now great the
world's gonna be in 50 years let me make
you optimistic we're taking one step
backwards you know why we're facing [ __ ]
we need to face
we've been faking the truth and so we're
taking one big step back and we're
dealing with it it's like it's gonna be
a painful [ __ ] decade it hasn't even
started we're gonna be dealing with a
lot of [ __ ] but let me tell you what our
grandkids are gonna be living through
they're gonna be living through a world
because of the full exposure of who we
are where everybody realizes everybody's
got fucked-up [ __ ]
everybody's there's not a person in here
not one person in here that doesn't do
something that we consider right now a
real flaw it's just the truth
it's just the truth we as a collective
have to go through the pain of that but
when we get on the other side like when
we're all old and we're looking at this
remember this talk that's pretty
egotistical but try to like try to build
on this yourself and forget where it
started let me go that route we're gonna
be happy because it's gonna be different
it's gonna be real real different
because everybody's gonna start
accepting people's shortcomings and
we're gonna very different conversations
and and things like marriage and things
like money and sex and race like we're
gonna have some real conversations over
the next 20 30 years get ready cuz this
isn't gonna stop and we we are just not
the animals that we wish we were and we
just have to face that own it go through
that painful process but we will be much
better people in 50 years from today
because of this time during this era
because the internet is exposing us and
I'm very grateful for that
I'm happy because the truth should win
but you've got to go through some [ __ ]
to get to the other side and that's what
we're gonna do that's cool on a holistic
level that I'm sure a lot of people
looking around here are very passionate
about on your own personal level do that
with yourself as a person and as an
entrepreneur and [ __ ] will go in a
totally different place I promise you
own your shortcomings own your strengths
surround yourself with the other [ __ ]
and stuff starts to pop thank you for
having me
[Applause]
[Music]